Sponsors segment Hoke, heck. Yeah my favorite part of this channel. Thank you everyone now
What do you say with me?
That's right. brick and balls not brick and bones brick n balls greatest game of all time
Completely impartial opinion, okay. Brick n balls is a comfortable
addictive and harder than it looks. Say it with me: comfortable, addictive and harder than it looks.
If you have 1,000 IQ, then this game is for you: because it takes a smart player goddammit
You think you're up for the challenge? Brick n balls! How much does this game cost Felix? You can download it for free!
Do I have to sell this anymore? I don't think so
Do I assume this game has already gotten 85 million downloads? Oh absolutely.
In the main gameplay, there are thousands of levels to beat
Thousands... Name one other game with thousand levels. It doesn't exist. There's also hundred ball challenge
I am playing right now, as we speak . Hundred ball challenge, where you try and get as high score as
possible with hundred balls, one launch. My high score is
558. Try and beat it. Gravity, another excellent game mode, which is an endless challenge mode with gravitational gameplay: god damn !
I know I'm not supposed to give my opinion because this is a sponsored video but goddamn: check out brick n balls!
Download break n balls
There are other interesting aspect of this game to explore for example Ruby Bank album collection
I don't think I need to say anything else. Download brick n balls!! (stop shouting plz)
link in description
Thank you break n balls for sponsoring this video. If you download it and comment in this video, in this video!, your high score
I will pick one person in the comments randomly, of course, that will win
5000 and the lucky winner will be selected
March 8th
Brofist, I'll give you a brofist if you download break n balls (do it bro)
Good job (u too)
I see light blue, but sometimes pain -
PewDiePie just makes TikTok videos to milk money
Oh, yeah, then why am I getting demonetized?!
This is so sad. UMG can lick my balls. No, for real.
Remove the strikes, you dumb ball. Remove the strikes, you ding Gong Gong! Don't make me go further than that
Now without further ado, let's
(spitting)-do into it (f**kin ew felix)
You're spunky. What are you doing? Dar you sniffing?
Spunky spunky
This is me, this is literally me when I spat-sniff-smack ass
"Yo spunky. What are you doing dog? He's sniffing". He's been there for a while
Spunky, what a great name, what a great time to be alive
Wasn't there a South Park episode where they sniff the cats and they makes them high?
Like cat piss makes you high or something like that. Is that true?
Do people get high using cat urine in one episode of South Park. Yeah, here we go. You actually can, wait people are saying no
Well, I guess I'm just gonna have to try it out. It looks like spunky had a great time. Okay?
I haven't had a great time in a while. Pop pewds needs a great time
"when
When you're terrible is that you can work with your own with your friend that you can choose by yourself"
The crossovers are so unnecessary at this point. I love it. I love it so much
My god everyone's making these now I mean it looks amazing, it looks really satisfying
How what's your full name?
hazel grace Lancaster
- Why are you looking at me like that -Because you're beautiful
"Oh my god". So, sweet! People are still making whatever that movie was called *hurt noise* memes
fantastic
It's the anime girl
God damn it
Stop! Stop with this (the circle), stop with megalovania
Stop with the 2015 memes. Okay. Let's
Do something fresh. Let's stop making the same videos over and over again. Here
I am trying to innovate and all these kids are just doing the same thing. I am really complaining...
But other people are doing the same thing while doing the same thing, joke explained everyone, let's move on!
No, I mean yes, I can laugh at that because this is not "You laugh you lose"!
This is just me criticizing kids. That's right, everyone. That was great, I enjoyed that
Very good, TikTok, I hate you sometimes. You gotta appreciate it at least the TikTok
Sooner or later, these TikTok kids will become famous
Some L.A. agency will say "hey you need to sign up with our crew" and then they'll go:
"yeah no, that sounds great, L.A. is great" and then they'll sign off all their videos so that they'll start claiming this freaking
TikTok compilations from all these kids. And there you go TikTok,
ruined. That's what happened to vine and I'll pretend that that's wasn't the case
Okay, the only one that can make videos out of TiKTok videos is me, and UMG apparently
Are you are you kidding me? Are you actually kidding me? Stop it! Stop with with a hand sign!
Oh my god *laughing*
So innocent and cute. What-- I guess it's worth mentioning like all the TikTok stuff
this week has just been this squared face guy, but
It's XXXTentation. It's copyrighted music in the background. I can't use it. Alright, let's just move on
I just... It needs like a little... You know what, you did it. You became TikTok famous. Congratulations.
Next time use a non copyrighted music goddammit
("Hit or miss" song)
So stupid! Is this what kids are doing these days, huh? They should be outside playing, not sticking their tongue out
Disgusting! "Not to be racist or anything, but asian people *horn sound*"
Damn
Well, I think this is pretty solid evidence that TikTok is in fact Vine 2 literally recreated, what the hell
(impersonating) Not to be racist, but asian people *horn sound*
How do you make that sound, how do you
*horn sound*
How do you do that? I mean, I'm impressed, women. Sometimes they impressed me. Don't quote me on them
Hey, bro, Chad check
Chad Check!
President of Chad, the population is increasing
The GDP is going up, the average lifespan
Chad check, everyone. Chad check. Chad. It literally looks like Chad
Oh, I never thought of that, this changes everything. Is that why chad is Chad? This brings whole new perspective to the meme
Stop it!
Stop it. Dr. Phil for meme review, anyone? Smash Like if you want it, it can happen
He sit, he is literally out there. If enough people smash Like, Dr. Phil will come out and host meme review
"What are you laughing at? -Nothing, nothing!"
Basically me
"Okay, so, you know the bigger shoe size the bigger penis. -Of course,
yeah, it's proportional. -Exactly, and then the bigger car the smaller the penis. -Okay, but what's your point?
So clowns have huge-"
Ok, I actually learnt something today: clowns have huge-
Jesus Christ
What is that?
Lol, why my dolphin not working?
I think there might be a murderer in my room. Can you help me find him?
Sorry, I said him I should have said them
How am I supposed to know that it's a guy I'm really sorry tik-tok
You should check their Twitter bio, cuz they will say he them or her or whatever
Okay, because that clearly needs to be stated in case oh god anyone makes a mistake.
"Hey bro, chad check!"
Chad check!
Yes, but what is the GPD of Chad? Oh my god, dude, Chad
Come on Chad
Come on, Chad. Chad is the only country that can save us from India. Let's get real here
Let's increase the gross domestic product of Chad.  Let's make it happen
If this video gets enough likes then it can happen
Now, I don't normally do this
But anyone that buys the merch, I will donate to Chad. That is a complete lie and false statement
But I will do it. Another not really TikTok, but still kind of TikTok
The absolute man-woman, Belle Delphine. Lol, why is my dolphin working?
Thank you Belle Delphine, very cool. Now I can use her in the thumbnail, for millions of extra views
Thank you, Belle Delphine, this is a blessing. Also. thanks for not striking my thumbnails. I really appreciate it
Thank you very much
Yeah!!!!
Only if you've subscribed to PewDiePie
Can you go out with the woman? If a women ask you out, you gotta ask her in following question:
"Are you sub'ed or not?", and if she says yes, well then sub again *horn sound*. Good joke, thanks.
- "Hey dude -What?
Hit or miss I guess they never miss, huh?
I told you next time you say hit or miss I will not miss
TikTok like; hey, it's another PewDiePie. I'll take it
Ain't gonna happen kiddo, okay
It's Elon Musk, literally this happened as well
Yeah
Hell yeah, tanner, well done, well done!
I will never ever play Fortnite ever again. This is what happens when I freaking rage in Fortnite
I break my freakin whole TV, man.
Oh cringe, dude
(impersonating) This is what happens. This is the consequences
Alright that's it for this week's TikTok
Hope you guys enjoyed this video, smash like, for my man spunky out here for helping us discover
That's all for me. See you guys tomorrow
Bye, bye. No brofist. You know you have- we have a goal to work ourself too. There will be brofist-
The fuck you looking at?